bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
donald trump qu'on retrouve sur les
ruines de commerce et de bâtiments
brûlés qui qualifie les manifestations
de terrorisme intérieur comment comment
peut-on interpréter cette visite du
président des états unis à qeynos chap
ok ça ressemble un président en faisant
de gouvernance mais tout le monde sait
c'est un secret de polichinelle que
c'est la campagne collègues électeurs
donc dans l'antre comme votre cas j'ai
bien dit a axé sa campagne sur les lois
et autres et pourquoi parce que
l'économie vont mal il a accès zone
campagne aux élections sur un économie
très performante et le co bid a anéanti
toute la croissance et un chômage de
masse et donc il a tourné sa campagne ce
sont des 10 décembre de nouveaux devoirs
blanche dans les banlieues blanches pour
les républicains modérés
c'est une campagne basée sur le coeur
vous pensez que donald trump temps
finalement de faire diversion pour faire
oublier la situation sanitaire dans le
pays mais aussi la situation économique
exactement à un toit mais les jambes
dans les images des manifestations des
pillages de ruines de propriété et avec
ces images les gens dans les banlieues
quoique trempe peuvent donner l'ordre
mais comme joe boyd et maman très
content parce que c'était un quart des
électeurs
ces images de violence ce ne sont pas
dans un pays imaginaire de l'avenir de
amérique dubaï ce sont les images de
président une chance maintenant la
société hautement colorisées c'est une
évidence et à la côté gauche avec une
voix minoritaires noire les noirs ne
représente que 12% de l'électorat
on avait des grandes manifestations anti
racistes à cause de leur racisme
institutionnel donc tranquillement c'est
pas le problème le problème c'est la
propriété c'est une campagne qui a bien
réussi pourriture unique celle dans les
années soixante dix et a sacré aussi
jouer parce que oui ce concept là où
kenosha est localisée c'est une étape
qui trompa gagner avec 10 me revoir en
2007 et donc joué la carte raciale
c'est un effort de la part de 30 de
regagner ce qu'il a perdu dans les
sondages parce que je ne gagne 3 5% à
toutes les sondages là bas vous disais
si j'ai bien entendu 12% de d'afro
américains aux états unis donc selon
vous on ne peut considérer que ce n'est
pas un enjeu pour la compagnie torres
potentiel réélection oui précisément la
semaine dernière c'est une convention
républicaine nationale rassemblement de
toutes les parties république a nommé
mme marie qu ils ont rentré quatre noirs
qui se disent entre eux n'est pas
raciste
l'enjeu là mais ce n'est pas pour
attirer le voit noir
lula s'est attiré les blanches qui
peuvent être rassurés que voter
républicain n'est pas être raciste
donc non je sais dans ces banlieues
blanches là où les gens votent ils
votent fortement
et c'est pas pour attirer les noirs pour
lui il abandonne les noirs c'est 12% ce
de la carte n'est pas importante
il perd dans tous les sondages dans les
états de noir en caroline du sud
un décès swing states et tente de
balayer le parti de vouloir probablement
va lui coûter mais dans d'autres états
comme risque en scène où les divisions
est grande et anna le soutien des blancs
qu il peut gagner avec ce carry et son
compagnon louis scan ci doivent être
voir sur cette optique
parce qu'il faut gagner 7 8 7 et est
dansiez pour gagner l'élection
ici ça l'actualité à louise can seniors
nous sommes à neuf semaines de
l'élection présidentielle 63 jours
exactement que disent les sondages est
ce que donald trump est en bonne posture
dans les sondages reste assise stable
donc thomas hayden reste une 9 points en
avance dans notre empire dans les sites
ce balancier cinq points mais il y avait
des problèmes que les sondages mes yeux
sont popularité mais le voir jours par
les têtes par l'état donc d'après le
sondage joe biden va gagner mais à dos
près l'expérience 2016 même avec une
avance dans le voit populaire dubaï
d'une poule et autres soirs dans le
collège électoral ou soit s'y trompe et
c'est une des choses qui est près du
site sans conteste son défaite dans le
hall approprient saint-yves centre notre
chambre des représentants merci beaucoup
de glace et y est je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur de droit et spécialiste
de sciences politiques américaines merci
pour ces précisions